Why are you crying here?
I got lost. And I can't find my mom.
What does your mom look like?
She is a tall and thin lady with long and straight hair.
What is she wearing?
She is wearing a dress with polka dots.
Look over there!
A woman with a polka-dot dress runs down the street.
She must be your mom.
Emmy throws the ball. And a puppy Billy chases it.
Then, Billy sees Cat. He drops the ball and chases Cat.
Cat runs down the street, and Billy chases him.
Cat runs into the forest, and Billy chases him.
Cat climbs up a tree. Billy turns to go home.
He cannot see the big house with a blue roof. He is lost.
Billy goes to Owl in the barn. Owl flies, and Billy chases her.
Then, Billy sees Emmy at the big house with a blue roof.